we begin with the war in ukraine where
intense fighting is raging for control
of the city of lizzie chunsk
it is the last stronghold of ukrainian
resistance in the hansk province in the
east
after weeks of clashes lizzie chance is
now the subject of competing claims
russian-backed fighters say they've
bought the city under their control a
claim the ukrainian army denies
a soldier waves a militia flag on a
bombed out building in a city they say
is liza chansky
moscow-backed separatists claimed to
have seized control of the city thought
to be the last stronghold of ukrainian
resistance in the luhansk region
is now under our control
yes under our full control a cleanup
operation is underway
but ukraine says the fight for lizzy
chansk is not over yet they say fierce
battles are continuing on the city's
outskirts and deny claims that lizard
chanska is surrounded
the ukrainian armed forces released
footage of what they said was an
explosion at a russian army warehouse in
eastern ukraine
as russian missile strikes continued to
rain down across the country killing
dozens
today the russian army continued to hit
our cities with missiles as of just this
evening there have been six missile
strikes a total of twelve missiles
in mikolayev in the donetsk region
airstrikes have continued
brutal hostilities continue along the
entire front line in donbass the epi
center of course in the cities of the
luhansk region
many have been forced to flee to other
parts of ukraine
with her three-year-old daughter in tow
nina bondar escaped lizachansk she fears
that even when the violence is over
there'll be nothing left to go back to
the city doesn't exist anymore it has
practically been wiped off the face of
the earth there is no humanitarian aid
distribution center it was hit the
building no longer exists just like many
of our houses
safe for now
families here try and get used to their
new lives in a sort of limbo never sure
if or when the next attack will come
but one thing is certain it will be a
long time before they can go home
correspondent emmanuel charles is in
odessa in southern ukraine emma both
sides are claiming some measure of
control in lizzy chansk in the east of
the country what can you tell us about
the situation there
good morning anthony well uh the
fighting is ongoing in lizzie chansky
not only also around
in the surrounding areas making it very
difficult to assess independently the
situation which we saw images of
pro-separatist leaders saying what they
say uh showing what they say is a
parading of russian and pro-russian
troops through lizzie chance but we do
not know if ukrainian armed forces
actually were
you know
retreated uh
to regroup strategically or if they were
chased out of the city what we know for
sure it is that feasts fighting
continues
in the area with russia's goal to
conquer the entirety of the province of
luhansk still
very much on the cards but a very very
volatile situation at the moment
you're in the port city of odessa in
southern ukraine a part of the country
that's been the target of increasing
russian shelling in recent weeks what's
the latest where you are
well uh the city of odessa
you know it's by the black sea so
obviously it's a vulnerable to missile
attacks
since most of them are launched from
from the black sea even from here you
can hear the sound of ukrainian
armed forces first you can hear the
ukrainian defense when missiles cross
over uh the region but you can also hear
the sound of artillery when ukrainian
forces uh attack russian positions in
mikolayev so it's a very uh like the
south of ukraine has been uh the scene
of heavy fighting with ukrainian armed
forces also claiming that they've been
destroying uh uh
russian uh armed vehicles that have been
destroying also uh uh
systems here in the south so we have two
fronts in the east where it seems that
this day uh the russian army has been
dominating a little but maybe also this
russian army is you know wasting a lot
of resources
there and maybe that's also strategy for
ukraine and here in the southern uh
front where ukraine has made significant
again significant victories over the
past few weeks
in another development emma the
government of neighbouring belarus a
close kremlin ally claims that a shot
down missiles launched by the ukrainian
army what would that mean if true and
does that actually match what you're
hearing from ukrainian authorities
well it has been reported uh here uh in
ukrainian media the ukrainian
authorities warned for uh weeks if not
months now that they that belarus would
be looking uh for a pretext to join the
russian forces and attack
ukraine as well this would open
again
a new front if you will and maybe this
was positive threats of having troops
marching on the capital kiev
again so there is a threat uh you know
in uh the western city of la vie which
uh uh is uh you know uh like uh close to
the polish border uh defense officials
ukrainian armed forces uh and ukrainian
defense have actually started to train
civilians in each area to defend
themselves in case of an invasion so
those threats are taking are taking uh
taken sorry very seriously indeed here
in ukraine dw correspondent emmanuel
chazin odessa thank you